william you live in anchorage i would
think if you lived in anchorage
there'd be this pressure to be out there
with a
bowie knife hunting canoeing
uh putting tennis racquets on your feet
and traipsing through the snow
yeah are you that kind of guy put it see
this was the first time i snowshoed
i was so drastically disappointed
because my only exposure to that was
like winnie the pooh when i was a kid
and you actually stay on top of the snow
it sucks man
i'm not i'm not the outdoorsman at all
oh no well i mean it's okay to not like
snowshoeing i tried it once and i
thought it's a total scam
it's just a good way to trip yeah it
just makes your feet
bigger uh and more clumsy and you're
still in the snow
uh that's someone's practical joke
that's lasted hundreds of years
oh having trouble getting through the
snow tie these oversized tennis rackets
to your feet
go ahead still having trouble t he keep
at it for a few hundred years
that's what i think snowshoeing is but
are you an outdoorsman
in other ways ah not really i mean i
like playing
sports outdoors but not like the
outdoorsman like
do you know how to hunt game and then
hunt it down and then
field dress it and then smoke it over a
flame and then eat it
oh yeah i when when i did go hunting
with my father-in-law
the only moose i saw on that hunt was
when i was waking up from a nap it had
snuck up on me
and my gun was out of reach so there's
wait a minute you went hunting with your
father-in-law in anchorage alaska right
you're out in the countryside in the
woods
and you go to sleep you see no game you
go to sleep
and when you wake up a moose is looking
at you and it's between you and your gun
it was well the gun was off to my left a
little bit the moose was about 15 feet
in front of me now tell the truth the
moose also had a gun right yeah
it was it was back for my lunch money
again
louis was like ah have a nice nap did
you yeah
don't even try for the gun there william
you won't make it
yeah um wow that's incredible so you did
nothing you just stared at the moose and
then it walked away
i tried to reach for the gun and it just
moves are fast man
moose are fast are they really i don't
think they are i
i just think of them just i think that
moose took its time
leaving william and i think
i don't think you had it in you to shoot
a moose and i don't blame you
would you have shot the moose if you
could i don't think you would have i
i would have if i could have because
it's good food but i
i did on the hunt i wound up getting a
grizzly bear
what you got a grizzly yeah that skull
wait a minute
right there i got a grizzly bear yeah
that's insanity
i first of all i've never uh grizzlies
are
are they're like a killing machine
grizzlies
yeah i'm fascinated by grizzly bears and
i happen to know that
they'll if they start charging you it
doesn't even matter if you have a
gun you're it's it's over i mean they're
practically bulletproof what did what do
you mean you got a grizzly
you had nine moose taunting you and you
did nothing
and then you say oh but i got a grizzly
yeah um
i so like i said i'm not an outdoorsman
my father-in-law he's been hunting since
he was like seven years
father-in-law sounds like a bully he's a
manly man
um and is he nick offerman you can tell
us
he's like nick offerman with a little
less hair on his head
and his mustache wow i think nick
offerman is playing a prank on you
yeah maybe that'd be a pretty fun prank
but you know i'm i'm
i'm it sounds to me i'm just getting the
cliche of you're this
very nice soft-spoken pleasant young man
who likes to probably stay inside and
uh work on his uh x-wing fighter model
and then
your father-in-law is like we're going
out to get the dreaded moose
and you're thinking i'd rather put on
your snow shoes
out we go is that what happens it i mean
that's not too far off i wouldn't have
gone if it weren't
kind of obligatory if i'm being honest
it was a great experience though in
hindsight like one of the best
experiences of my life so wait a minute
so you've told us about
basically you know you you got moose to
the left of you moose to the right but
they're outwitting you at every turn
tell us how you bagged the grizzly i i
was i was up in a stand and we were just
kind of sitting there for
like three or four hours uh and
as we were sitting there we heard some
wrestling off to the right and and he's
like hey like there's a moose start
calling it in
and so we start raking and we just use
this button raking i don't know what
you're talking about
you use a bucket lid and you just kind
of scrape a branch and it kind of sounds
like when a moose is
raking their antlers on a tree so we
start raking
and it starts raking back at us and then
she starts saying i'm a moose
yeah yeah exactly i'm a moosh you should
try it sometime
so bad at it i'm a moose that's what i'd
be doing yeah
oh i'm a moose so that that moose then
started coming downwind of us because
that's what they'll do
i found out this is all information that
i'm just regurgitating from him
they'll come down wind of you to see
what you're all about and
get a whiff of you and right when he got
about parallel to us
maybe 30 40 yards into the forest we
heard what sounded like a like a
pit bull just growling right in our ears
but it was a it was a grizzly bear like
150 yards away but it sounded like it
was just
right up on the ear and he looked at me
he's like do you want to shoot a moose
or
a bear and in my head i'm like i don't
see the moose yet
but i see the bear now and uh
i lined up my shot and luckily
basically killed it instantly which you
can't really do on purpose
wow i think given the choice between you
said moose or grizzly
i'd have shot the father-in-law that
guy's
you know and first of all is it fun to
be up in a stand i just would feel like
lee harvey oswald
up there you know comes driving by in a
motorcade that's where's the
sportsmanship in that you want to be
down there on the ground
fighting it with your own bare hands
we've been we've been hiking out a lot
i'd gotten lost earlier that week even
though
there's relatively good paths and stuff
like i said it's not my thing
i i was safe up there yeah i'm glad you
were up there i'm glad you're safe
um what do you do then with the grizzly
uh well there's a whole lot of stuff
that goes on
um they'll size it and if you want to
you can like enter it in to see if it
falls
in like certain size categories that
certain associations will like
give you awards for so i actually it
wound up being that this grizzly bear
was an inch and three quarters shy of
the world record
what yeah of the what do you mean of the
world record
world record you mean the world record
for interior grizzly wait you said world
not it just in alaska but in
all of the world yeah so boone and
crockett is the association that is like
they measure the biggest fish and game
they get recorded
and there's kodiak grizzlies like the
coastal ones and then there's interior
grizzly
you're not an outdoorsman wow and you go
out on a hunt
and you're so not an outdoorsman that
you fall asleep and when you
and a moose has to wake you up and show
you where your gun is
yeah like oh you you dropped this uh
there you go and you also dropped your
ammo yes moose no problem
that's how much of a of an outdoorsman
you are
then when you least expect it you shoot
at a grizzly
you miss but your miss shot kills it
instantly and then it turns out to be
slightly
slightly slightly less than the biggest
grizzly interior grizzly in the world
that is an accurate
summary